[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans sion par
les sports il fait beau il fait chaud et
vous aurez encore le droit aujourd'hui à
un talk e volcaniques sur l'actualité
sportive du département
nos chroniqueurs sont en effervescence
aujourd'hui sont quatre autour de cette
table présentation en musique on
commence à ma droite il fait à chauffer
la piste à chaque fois qu'il enfourche
son vélo et donne des sueurs froides à
tous ses concurrents dans la catégorie
masters c'est son grand retour sur ce
talk le capitaine yann dujarrier du club
de vélizy 78 est avec nous on sent
michael bonsoir
comment allez-vous yann très bien voilà
vous fait peur à tous vos adversaires
non non pas de haut parce que y'en a qui
me battent encore gagner sûrement alors
du père est il me bat régulièrement donc
non je ne me fait pas peur à tous les
adversaires on passe à ma gauche un
musique son regard va sans doute nous
faire fondre à l'habitude de réchauffer
à l'atmosphère en réalisant des figures
de pole dance dance halte à versailles
toutes les semaines c'est trop sauvons
notre ambassadrice de charme
hélène de la grange nous fait le plaisir
de lumière sur cette finition bonjour
moi je suis ravi d'être ici encore mais
apparemment ça dafu aujourd'hui à bas
prix un petit peu mon sujet c'est de
faire mieux le maximum mais c'est bien
de frapper
est-ce que c'est difficile de faire de
la pole dance en général quand il fait
chaud
colas et c'est un peu compliqué on a des
choses à gérer mais non ça c'est une
pratique un peu adapté on arrive quand
rien faire pas mal de trucs on peut en
faire
oui on en passe de l'autre côté à
musique c'est notre spécialiste football
ans il arrive à mettre en effervescence
tout un stade avec ses analyses
et aussi bouillant 15 la tan ibrahimovic
c'est seulement son 3e si on parlait
sports georges gomis président du
plaisir sporting club est avec nous
bonjour à tous bonjour président quand
allez-vous superbe
alors êtes-vous aussi bouillant 15 la
tan ibrahimovic si voulions possible
gouvernants mais imprévisible oui on
termine à ma gauche musique qu'il a la
fièvre du cheval depuis tout jeune et il
est devenu un bouillon cavalier
international on surnomme dans cette
émission le zorro yvelinois le plaisir à
raul aux côtés d'autres y est avec nous
sur ce plateau
bonjour à houlle donc comment va le
zorro évinois très bien très bien
je continue à faire la loi sur mon fief
content de retrouver les copains très
heureux comme d'habitude nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de basket sera pas réussi à
terminer quatrième de national troyes
nous évoquerons également le marathon de
paris a couru ni montant a défié la
chronique en courant les 42km pieds nus
les avant d'élever développé ces thèmes
on ouvre une page en page baseball
c'était la rentrée pour les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux dans le stade de
jean maréchal lésigny montain recevait
le plus que de paris le 8 avril pour
leur premier match de la saison en d1
nos rencontres fermées qui a vu les
yvelinois s'imposer 1 à 0 grâce aux
vénézuéliens rogner mattera nos un match
ou un autre vénézuélien s'est également
illustré son nom ailleurs franck lopez
lui des cinq recrues du club à thiais
attiré plus d'une centaine de lancer
pendant la partie on écoute le coach de
l'équipe rodolphe le meur relancer en
tout cas sur mon attitude il a maîtrisé
vraiment beaucoup mieux que le lanceur
adverse
au niveau des stray cats il a une
dizaine de strike out donc il a vraiment
maîtrisé son match
le recrutement de you're franck lopez
n'a pas été le seul coup d'éclat des
cougars sur le mercato de baseball son
côté plusieurs joueurs venus de la
france et de l'étranger c'est sans doute
le meilleur recrutement de l'histoire du
club selon le coach il me l'a confirmé
lors de l'émission dû 7 8 sport sur
notre chaîne qui est vraiment très
sélectif est aujourd'hui en tout cas
pense avoir pris les meilleurs dont
gabriel on a pour l'instant tu viens
d'arriver aussi un lanceur qui a une
grosse expérience aux états unis donc
le recrutement est à la hauteur de mes
ambitions c'est le meilleur boulot dans
l'histoire du club aujourd'hui chaque
recrutement a difference sont des années
après vous savez c'est un peu la loterie
c'est on se dit on fait venir des gens
on regarde un peu quand même leurs
statistiques les des années précédentes
et puis on a un peu d'écho notamment des
joueurs quand gabriel qui ont déjà
évolué en championnat français mais
après oui on pense que aujourd'hui on
est on a fait un des meilleurs
recrutements de le meilleur recrutement
de l'histoire du club d'après rodolphe
le meur la question sur ce thème le
recrutement fait-il l'équipe
oui ou non non le partager enfin petit
duel entre vous et l'aisne et georges
hélène vous commencez je trouve que
c'est quand même là la principale
composante c'est vraiment pour moi le
plus important de choisir bien les
éléments après évidemment il ya tout
l'encadrement tous les entraînements etc
mais sans un bon recrutement
on va finalement pas très loin donc
après il faut une bonne cohésion
d'équipé mon travail mais pour moi c'est
au minimum 50% du travail georges un bon
recrutement oui c'est certes c'est ça
aide à faire comment faire une bonne
saison ou pas mais
une équipe c'est le coach quoi c'est
déjà le staff technique les designers
comment le staff technique et
observateurs ils connaissent les joueurs
et qu'on espère leurs statistiques
l'environnement le changement de club
pour le joueur ne s'est pas évident il
peut il peut ne pas donner les mêmes
performances par rapport à le même
rendement donc je pense que la
composante le recrutement c'est une
chose mais la bonne équipe je pense l
intégration et le travail du coach qui
va permettre d'avoir une bonne équipe
là où l'on faisait tier partagé oui
j'étais mitigé parce qu est-ce qui vous
ont convaincu
je pense que dans dans la logique
sportive le recrutement ne fais pas
l'équipe il est un paramètre déterminant
mais j'aime it is et parce que je pense
que il prend une place bien plus bien
plus importante et bien plus
déterminante quant il s'agit d'un sport
qui vient d'un autre continent et que
justement on fait traverser l'atlantique
à des à des sportifs pour venir jouer
chez nous là à ce moment là
effectivement le le recrutement joue un
rôle beaucoup plus important c'est
pourquoi j'ai donné un avis mitigé et
âme de l'autre côté je me souviens que
je rejoins du coup
du coup raul sur sûr du fait qu'un cul
non pas du fait que ce sport est un peu
exotique c'est vrai que faire venir des
deux très bons joueurs d'autres d'autres
continents où ce sport est un peu plus
faim d'autres d'autres pays où ce sport
est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus répandue
en effet il va avoir avoir une
importante maintenant voilà le
recrutement pour moi ne fait pas tout je
suis assez d'accord que l'esprit équipe
c'est le coach qui va là qui va le voir
inculquer qui va donner cette dynamique
ensuite il ya aussi tous les
préparateurs physiques dans une dans une
grosse structure qui ont vraiment une
grosse importance parce que vous pouvez
avoir le meilleur joueur du le meilleur
joueur du monde si physiquement vous
n'arrivez pas à le préparer à la menée
haut à son meilleur niveau il aura pas
le rendement qu'ils pouvaient avoir
qu'ils pouvaient avoir ailleurs qu'ils
pouvaient avoir avant donc donc c'est
vrai que c'est une
c'est plusieurs éléments mis bout-à-bout
qui font que 1 qui font prendre une
mayonnaise ou qui font prendre
voilà si vous avez un bonheur fou une
bonne huile ben si la moutarde est pas
terrible
vous avez raté là vous avez raté votre
marionnette je connaissais pas du tout
cette expression non mais c'est quoi
cette vous venez ici j'ai deux mois a
fait de moi alors georges et ils ont
réussi à terminer en demi finales de
playoffs
l'année dernière 120 recrutements
stratosphérique finalement c'est
possible d'aller loin en d1 de baseball
sans avoir forcément les joueurs majeurs
oui mais là il qu'ils ont peut-être
aussi comment analyser leur saison et
puis d un pressenda ils ont ils ont
peut-être ils ont peut-être ciblé des
joueurs précis pour pouvoir leur
permettre de passer à l'étagé supérieur
à l'étape supérieure
mais en finale de play-off et les
joueurs qu'ils ont ciblé j'espère qu'ils
vont donner magna notamment ailleurs
franck lopez j'en parlais précédemment
et je vais l'année dernière chez les
champions d'espagne avec les marines de
tenerife il a commencé le baseball à 6
ans avec son père il a joué avec les
detroit tigers jusqu'en 2014
il est élu meilleur lanceur de l'année
en summer league en 2011
vaut mieux l'avoir dans son équipe un
clairement georges en gp et il a 27 ans
donc il n'est pas en fin de carrière
donc là c'est vrai que d'avoir 27 28 ans
là pour tous les sports généralement
quand on a un gars stage là on a mon âge
vérité on a la maturité on a tout ce
qu'il faut on se connaît et puis bon je
pense que là
si l'intérêt le seul point
d'interrogation c'est le temps qui va
mettre à s'adapter parce que changer de
continent changer de pays
bon des fois on est seul on les sent
chemin des amis en toute première
rencontre
voilà donc mais je pense que c'est un
gros plus vaut mieux l'avoir dans son
équipe toute une saison je pense qu'ils
auraient faire des grosses performances
et je souhaite de tout coeur qu'ils
fassent les la finale de play-off
les cougars face la finale de play-off
voilà et lan il faut gérer aussi
peut-être certains ego quand on a
forcément recrutement plus conséquent
chacun arrive avec son bagage
d'expérience de victoire de notoriété
aussi donc après c'est ça rejoint peu ce
que disait georges on a beau avoir une
un bon recrutement il faut donc 1 2 bon
coach et cetera
mais aussi finalement
comment dire une bonne installer une
bonne cohésion entre chacun chacun
trouve bien une place sans être lésé
sans être l'ami une place qui est la
sienne c'est ça doit pas être évident à
gérer sa fossette gt line de rien un
sport très individuel même si il se
prépare même s'il se pratique en équipe
et il faut être bon à tous les postes
mais mais c'est vrai que c'est quand
même
c'est quand même plus individuelle que
ne peut l'être le foot le hand ball le
basket etc
c'est un peu c'est un peu différent donc
en effet des individualistes et forte
au baseball vont avoir une importance
sur une équipe à votre avis le râble à
votre avis est-ce qu'il faut gérer les
égos des fois dans les équipes de
baseball effective enfin à chacun sa
spécialité donc de toute façon chacun
doit être bon dans ce qu'il a dans le
poste qu'il a et à ce moment là
la rivalité c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut complètement écrasée parce que
ensuite je crois que les qualités des
arts vont être complètement annulée par
la mauvaise mentalité dans une équipe
donc pour gérer les ego peut demander à
une ânerie peut-être mais à ivry le
maraîchage et au mes qui doit être qui a
des petits soucis d'ego dans son
vestiaire cette année il ya également
une particularité il n'y aura pas de
descente en d1 carhaix le championnat
comptait plus d'equipe l'année prochaine
il ya des possibilités aussi de voile de
se planter peut-être sur certains postes
en se disant finalement c'est pas si
grave
georges moi je pense qu au hamas ou ça
casse oui je pense que quand ya pas de
décembre déjà sur plan
mental
c'est comment c'est quand même un préfet
enfin ça permet aux gens de jouer avec
moins de pression et je pense que à ce
niveau là des gens vont pouvoir
justement prendre plus de risques
pouvoir pouvoir
je pense qu'il va y avoir un meilleur
championnat et il risque même d'avoir
des surprises parce que quand il ya pas
la descente et je pense que tout le
monde va jouer sa chance grandement et
le fait qu'ils aient pas une descente je
pense que c'est une très bonne chose là
dedans d'autres sports on quand on voit
que quand il ya vous il ya moins de
descente quand il ya moins de enfin
quand il ya trois équipes qui descendent
ou quatre équipes y descendre bas les
championnats et les mois et il est moins
les moins sympathiques ils aient pu il y
arrive plus de tensions plus défensif
est là aujourd'hui je pense que là avec
le recrutement qu'ils ont fait je pense
grande mois qui vont jouer leur chance à
fond même si aussi comment rohan rohan
le réélire leur étaient supérieurs à
l'année d'avant
je pense que cette année vont peut-être
rééquilibrer les choses
on va jouer au petit jeu des pronostics
hélène ils ont comme un pour cent de
chances d'être champion
à votre avis et là j'en ai aucune idée
aucune idée le cloud dans la saison 6
dans la salle c'est cette fois cette
saison
je mettrai 70% 70% georges moi je
mettrais un peu plus je mettrais 80% il
ya trop important
champion et yann trop tôt trop tôt on en
parle dans un mois puisque la saison du
calme relativement courte en baseball on
me reparle dans un mois restants se
termine au mois de septembre
oui mais une trêve estivale de travestis
mal delà de deux mois donc les ailes et
elle est relativement courte après à le
baseball on poursuit ceux ci ont parlé
sport part du basket le club de trappes
s'est très largement imposée ce samedi à
14 avril contre quand le score est sans
appel 115 à 66 face une équipe du haut
de tableau qui occupait la deuxième
place avant la rencontre
un résultat qui permet aux trappistes de
terminer la saison à la quatrième place
on regarde cet extrait du 7-8 sport du
16 avril dernier c'est surtout envie
j'ai l'impression et l'osmose en fait
dans les films qui s'est fichée produits
tout au tout au long de la saison qui a
fait que voilà samedi c'était
l'apothéose et tout rentrait ces anciens
à 66 contre la troisième équipe du place
du classement exactement
ben en fait c'est un peu le chili un peu
frustrant cette saison c'est que on a
battu toutes les premières équipes enfin
la première et la deuxième est la
deuxième équipe on les a battus en aller
retour
la troisième équipe on vient d enlever
les enfants c'est chez nous c'est ce qui
a fait un peu que la saison était avec
des hauts et des bas en fait les
trappistes ont donc réussi à battre les
trois premiers du classement mais ils
ont perdu contre le dernier et l'avant
dernier la question sur ce thème tra
peut-il avoir des regrets sur cette
saison où voter oui non on voit le
classement qui s'affiche oui vous êtes
partagés lewin raul vous commencez donc
ils peuvent avoir des regrets forcément
parce que quand on crée des exploits
paris en fin de saison on se rend compte
que le niveau était là et que c'est
peut-être des petites choses des petits
réglages qui ont fait que la saison
avait mal avait mal démarré
maintenant c'est vrai que le terme le
gmi j'aime hiver mais le terme regret il
est assez péjoratif parce que de toute
façon
on a en fin de saison que je dire quand
on part but du bas on espère que
remonter donc de toute façon une des
belles victoires comme ça derrière on
peut que s'en réjouir malgré tout c'est
georges fait d'accord avec raul moi oui
le crowd je pense que un championnat
assez long et la de battre de trouver la
motivation intrinsèque pour battre pour
battre des équipes du haut du tableau
cc c'est beaucoup plus facile en gros
parce quand on est derrière on a
toujours envie de taper taper les
premiers mais le plus gros regret qu'ils
doivent ils ont réussi à battre les
premiers oui voilà il va te les premiers
et les deuxièmes les 3e et eux ils
finissent quatrièmes donc à ils ont
perdu des points contre les le bas de
tableau et ayez le pour peaux ternes
pour faire un très bon championnat est
arrivé à la fin le 1er ou 2e ou dans les
trois premiers bains le championnat
c'est le championnat du bas parce que
les équipes bio généralement d les
équipes du haut qui se font pas taper
par les équipes du bas et celle du
milieu de tableau après même c'est
perdre un ou deux 2 matchs avec le haut
du tableau
ils ont réglé dans leurs affaires leurs
saisons sur les matches du bas et du
milieu de tableau donc trappe
dommage donc je ne sais pas si vous
vouliez monter si vous vous le vouliez
vous avez des regrets si vous voulez
rester une année de plus pour pas faire
des voyages plus longs mais c'est un
phénomène de voir c'est assez courant
dans le sport quand on considère qu'une
qu'une saison est plus ou moins rap et
c'est souvent là vu qu'on a pu on est
plus on joue plus aux joueurs de la
pression on sort son meilleur jeu
ça se voit dans le tennis est un jeu
dans plein d'autres sports donc c'est
des choses qui arrivent
j'ai pensé que la saison a été compliqué
on va dire au niveau émotionnel
quand on perd quand on est dernier les
avant-derniers forcément ensuite c'est
c'est plus ou moins du practice on
chercha on cherche à développer de
nouvelles stratégies qui payeront
peut-être pour l'année prochaine donc ça
arrive que l'on se transcende
ils n'ont pas géré leur saison pour pas
justement pour ne pas monter de peur de
ne pas voir le budget économique devant
justin président nous a dévoilé qu'ils
n'avaient pas forcément les moyens
financiers pour monter dès cette saison
il était au fond du trou financièrement
il ya cinq ans et là ne doivent pas
aller trop vite car les clips des
comptes est encore fragile et forcément
une n2 avec les voyages plus longs avec
des forcément des styles plus compliquée
à jouer entraînerait forcément un
mercato beaucoup plus conséquent vois tu
vois ce que je vois quand même sur le
sur le championnat c'est que entre la
première et la dernière équipe fait que
10 points 29 pour la dernière équipe 39
pour la très serré voilà ça c'est un
championnat très serré donc en effet ce
assez ils ont gagné ils ont ils ont
battu les plus grosses écuries du de
leur championnat maintenant voilà ça
s'est joué à des détails et ça ces jeux
d'une taille pour tout le monde
il n'y avait pas d' équipes qui étaient
largement dominatrice tout le monde est
dans un point de de l'équipe du dessus
il ya 39 37 35 36 35 33 et voilà tout
est très très très très dense donc je
vais presque un petit peu comme hélène
de mettre un bémol finalement ils ont
peut-être pas tant de regret que ça à
voir surtout qu'au final ça les arrange
par rapport à la gestion
aux côtés budgétaire ou complexes à
cette question économique c'est plutôt
là peut-être qu'un regret une partie
c'est à dire qu'on ferait avec un
fraisier on a freiné les joueurs on leur
a dit voilà vous avez fait le job contre
contre les preuves contre les meilleurs
vous allez mettre le frein contre contre
les moins bons et c'est aussi ça qui a
fait que le championnat s'est resserré
au niveau au niveau des points
maintenant j'espère surtout c'est qu'il
le regretteront pas peut-être que ils
n'auront pas la même opportunité de
remonter les j'espère qu'ils ne
regretteront pas avoir du tout pour ce
genre de ce genre de démarche
moi je serais plus justement justement
pour aller récolter des fonds trouvés
des trouvait à peut-être un nouveau
sponsor par le biais d'un d'une
stratégie marketing mais on se brûle pas
les étapes
quand on est capable de les zelles
pardon quand on est capable de battre
les meilleurs sportivement on parle bien
d'argent là on parle pas de sport sur le
plan sportif si on est ce qu'il ya il
évoque pas la raison la raison du niveau
pour monter ou pas quand c'est que
l'argent il faut se battre
c'est ça qui fait la beauté du sport
c'est qu'après on ne saura jamais si
finalement s'il avait gagné pour premier
dernier il aurait pu finalement comme
vous le disais tout à l'heure avoir de
la pression sur les derniers matches est
sûre et peut-être des défaites
finalement face aux gros en tous les cas
moi je suis pratiquer le sport avec des
limites des limites déjà préconçues moi
ça me va pas du tout à une logique qu'il
est là
on se retrouve sa coque ça fait quoi
c'est top 3 une équipe de trois donc
voila j'aimerais simplement on saura
plus tard s'ils ont eu raison pas c'est
s'il arrive à avoir la montée entend
enfin l'année prochaine et qu'il
approchait mais voilà les prochaines
années mais c'est vrai qu'il va pas
falloir l'a pas falloir avoir le regret
de se dire on a raté le coche
on a raté le coche en 2018 allez il
aurait pu aussi éventuellement jouer
leur championnat à fond terminer premier
puis refuser la montée puis le deuxième
serait monté à leur place au 3e voilà
donc mais par derrière en terminant
progrès en terminant premier est ce que
ça n'avait pas finalement il nous faut
c'est une excuse peut-être pour moi oui
ça peut être moins jeu quand on fait du
sport mais même des joueurs des joueurs
vous leur dites vous leur dites le
scénario il est comme ça c'est
impossible si vous jouez c'est
impossible d'autant plus qu'ils ont des
primes des mois ils ont des primes de
match quand ils viennent enfin les faire
à ce niveau là et quand il gagne il ya
ils ont des fixé ou des primes de match
quand ils viennent ils vont pas jouer
ils vont pas jouer la perte c'est moi
j'y crois pas maintenant maintenant moi
un dans d'autres sports
aux beaux l'un d'eux dimanche matin
grand les gars ils sont là ils refusent
d'en monter en ph parce que quand ils
jouent en ligne il faut qu'ils se
déplacent un peu pro bowl voilà
donc eux dans l'ordre dans le même cas
pas voulu terminer premier vous refusez
la montée c'est le deuxième qui monte et
puis ça vous fait une belle pub parce
que les jeux les gens vous êtes premier
vous montez pas vos meilleurs joueurs
partent mais derrière il y en a d'autres
qui vont venir parce qu'ils savent que
derrière vous avez une peau temps vous
allez avoir le potentiel pour cette
année surtout trappe avait un coach
d'exception steed tchicamboud je rappel
il est passé par chalon sur saône nancy
limoges roanne paris levallois
il a remporté une médaille d'argent aux
championnats d'europe en 2011
il faut garder pour la saison prochaine
oui oui il faut le garder il faut le
garder ce vote regardez où ils seront
suivis l'an prochain s'il continue à
être sur cette dynamique n'est pas
encore sûr on ne sait pas encore s'il va
rester la saison prochaine un nouveau
père et donc ça démontrera pas c'est
peut-être aussi voilà on peut on risque
de perdre le coach on n'ose pas la
montée elle et après si on a vu la
montée peut-être que le coach aurait
elle serait restée aussi y moi je pense
qu'ils ont peut-être joué un peu avec le
feu
on nous verra là ils sont en bonne
position par raoul quand même pour la
saison prochaine avec un coach comme ça
avec une dynamique d'équipé en restant
dans la même division bien sûr ils ont
mon avis du coup il ya maintenant la
pression de d'être obligé d'être premier
il faut que les soins peut-être plus
attendu par les eaux mais qu'il faut
voir qu'il va descendre parce qu'il peut
y avoir des descentes un peu surprise en
n2 et il se retrouvait des très gros
voilà un jeu dangereux
un jour après cette large page résultats
nous allons passer à notre coup de
projecteur dans notre coup de projecteur
je vous propose de découvrir un sportif
qui défient à la chronique et qui a fait
le buzz lors du dernier marathon de
paris
selon sidy diallo a 63 ans est é montain
couru pieds nus et a terminé en moins de
quatre heures mais cet athlète est un
habitué la cour au total 21 marathon
pieds nus sur ses 160 participation au
marathon en huit ans on écoute sa
réaction
la première fois que je suis sorti de
chez moi à pied nu c'était un juin 2015
de montigny et donc ça fait moins de
trois ans le début est très difficile
mais maintenant au moins sur l'asphalté
quand je suis l'asphalt je n'ai aucun
problème pour les pieds nus et des
halles à paris je vais réaliser mon l'un
devait mal tourner le plus rapide en
trois heures
54 et j'ai enchaîné donc
sept jours plus tard à bonn cette île
dimanche dernier avec et notre moral
afin de pieds nus et là j'ai réalisé mon
meilleur temps pieds nus sur la distance
du marathon
23h47 la question sur ce thème est il
possible de courir pieds nus
oui ou non il le fait ce que c'est
possible pour tout le monde
ces questions dans les faits tout le
monde peut courir pieds nus
on apprend à mettre des chaussures ont
obtenu non mais moi je cours pas des
noms mais en soi oui mais par contre
c'est d'un inconfort et je pense qu'il
faut vraiment s'habituer tout le monde
est pas c'est presque une philosophie
mais même il en parler puis un côté un
peu un peu écolo il me semble dans sa
démarche il y avait un projet sartre ou
rose lui voilà c'est ça un peu un peu
nature mais
dans les faits oui on peut après est-ce
qu'on va être supportée est ce que on
aura envie de faire des marathons comme
lui il fait entier pieds nus
je suis pas sûr que ça en balle beaucoup
il y en a qui testeront peut-être mais
moi je salue ce genre de démarche mais
bon eux
quand même plus des homo sapiens faut
s'habituer et puis l'être humain a
évolué il c'est quelque part en
s'améliorant il sait aussi fragilisé
on n'est plus capable de faire de
parcourir justement ces kilomètres dans
la jungle
pieds nus et en plus la plupart des fins
la plupart un bon un grand pourcentage
de personnes font face aussi à des
pathologies qu'il faut qu'on règle de
manière orthopédique par des chaussures
c'est pas pour rien que les chaussures
de les vraies chaussures de course scène
pour la santé avec un soutien de voûte
plantaire coûte cher c'est parce
qu'elles sont adaptés donc qu grâce lui
soit rendue mais s'est pas adapté à tout
le monde c'est pas une pub que je ferais
je pense qu'on ferait face à deux de
sérieuses blessures surtout sur des
distances comme le marathon georges
c'est vous impressionne oui je suis
fortement impressionné d'autant plus que
chez les people au niveau de la vidéo de
la fréquence du sol si je pourrai pieds
nus j'aurai je crois que des gros
problèmes de de commandes
oui tout on ne peut pas courir pieds nus
en voilà qui ne le dit pas dans sa
théorie tous vraiment ne peut pas que
voilà parce que déjà la pousse de pied
est drôlement important des ide opposé
vers l'avant d'opposer alors que les
pieds plats va ils doivent poser à plat
ce qu'ils soient un petit peu valgo
niveau des au niveau des genoux vers
l'intérieur donc ce qu'ils y en qui son
arc et pareil doivent aller un peu sur
les côtés
donc on voit aussi l'usure des
chaussures des gens quand on fait du
sport quand on ne dise pas nos
chaussures de la même manière mais
maintenant il doit avoir une excellente
pose deux pieds et une une course
assez souple pour pas avoir de problèmes
articulaires quoi il y voit la ville de
tendinite il de tendinites et moi je dis
vraiment bravo parce que les gens qui
est bon il sait mieux c'est pas le seul
et l'unique
mais il fait partie des très rares et je
le salue grandement et genre je le
respecte grandement et et je l'encouragé
à continuer tant qu'il peut et que j'ai
eus souhaite aucun aucun comment quand
pépins physiques
voilà mes soixante trois ans entre vous
et le dotant pucelage encore mais c'est
merveilleux c'est il y a
et c'est bien que vous lui ouvrez une
petite tribune et que le marathon
derrière il a fait le buzz
il est bien sûr de nombreux médias la
suite au gratin il ya trois ans il le
rappeler donc moi j ai déjà rivés sur ce
marathon j'ai vu un espagnol courir en
espadrilles avec une espadrille johnny
n'est ce pas guéri rouge et paraît un
peu compliquée me demandais si dini à
l'espagnol de nous raconter leur
marathon
par contre l'espagnol fait une très
belle perf' il est en moins de trois
heures et il fait un truc un truc assez
assez impressionnant donc
donc je pense que il ya des relais de la
recherche au niveau des chaussures qui
sont qui sont faites pour pouvoir gagner
tous ces petits gars marginaux qui
permettent d'améliorer sa performance
mais dans l'est dans les techniques
ancestrales il ya peut-être aussi des
choses à aller chercher à ne pas oublier
voilà un au niveau de la médecine en
tout cas sur les médecins il ya des
avantages et des inconvénients les
avantages il ya une réduction du coût
énergétique grâce à la diminution du
poids des chaussures l'augmentation de
la fréquence de foule et on a moins de
blessures comme les hématomes ou sous
l'os ou longues ou des ampoules cantons
contre pieds nus forcément les
inconvénients plus de problèmes au
niveau des tendons la plante du pied
devenu trop fragile également donc ça
peut être également dangereux le courir
notamment sur le bitume
vous êtes d'accord avec les médecins
aussi pâle médecin autres cette table
mais est ce que vous êtes d'accord
remarque simplement que ont fait face on
fait face à des problèmes mineurs
quand on court avec avec des chaussures
et tout de suite sans chaussures on
parle de tendons par l'articulation la
ccd ce sont des incidents à conséquence
un donc en tout cas pour sidy diallo
c'est tout à fait naturel de courir
pieds nus on écoute sa philosophie le
corps humain parfait j'espère que le
tuteur le corps humain est parfait le
corps et chaque des individus de chaque
espèce animale est parfait pour la
survie de l'espèce en saône habitat
naturel
il ya aucun autre animal qui portent des
chaussures et l'animal homo sapiens
n'est pas de chaussures que depuis très
peu de temps sur une histoire de trois
millions d'années
donc on va on va pas faire des études
si on doit faire des études s'est montré
en quoi les chaussures sont utiles et
des news est d'accord avec lui il faut
faire des études pour savoir pourquoi on
porte des chaussures n'ont pas forcément
mais je pense que c'est plus vraiment
une protection une protection de pied
ou les chaussures sont apparus à mon
avis même à l'époque des des premiers
hommes y avaient déjà en fait on avait
il se couvrait déjà les pieds selon les
saisons et c'est donc il ya déjà eu des
habits fin dé façon d'habiller les pieds
après là pour la course s'est vraiment
développée
voilà des chaussures particulière
maintenant de courir pieds nus
c'est je pense pas qu'on soit
qu'on soit resté comment dire fait pour
ça pour rester même déjà pieds nus tout
le temps c'est un peu compliqué et puis
courir dans des efforts sur des terrains
qui sont voilà qui sont plus
conflit purement à aux homo sapiens il
ya du verre partout il ya lui je pense
qu'on n'a pas les mêmes la même
structure de pau je pense que ça a
vraiment évolué on n'est plus vraiment
fait pour pour ce genre de de
l'environnement les plus propres quoi
alors il n'est pas le seul sportif en
tout cas à courir pieds nus il y avait
notamment le champion olympique
éthiopien
je pense que vous en rappelez il ya
dujarrier en 1960 et 1964 abebe bikila
qui courait pieds nus comme on peut le
voir finalement il a rien inventé
ça c'est dit diallo mais sur nos pieds
donc enfin on marche très rapidement et
est en effet dans in an il n'a rien
inventé maintenant voilà ils essayent
quelque chose il démontre quelque chose
que c'est possible
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est plutôt c'est
pouvoir comparer à une personne qui
aurait la même carrière que lui et qui
quoi avec des jeux sur savoir s'il fait
des performances qui sont meilleurs ou
moins bonnes et et là on aurait aimé on
aurait des informations supplémentaires
maintenant parce que des personnes qui
font de marathon entre un deux trois ans
il y en a il y en a d'autres
il ya des gens qui font du vélo à 104
mais un marchand voilà pourquoi pas le
site est tout à fait et donc s'est vu
aux jeux olympiques bon là et même des
jeux olympiques récent des chapelets de
wons récent des femmes courir pieds nus
aussi sur alors sur un stade
d'athlétisme qui est qui en tartan tard
quand c'est plus qu'on sait pas vraiment
qui est en matière et qui permet de
récupération pouvoir le faire plus
facilement une petite athlétisme mais
donc voila moi ça me
un moment mais pas forcément nouveau est
un mouvement qui est né dans les années
70 aux états unis vont finalement c'est
un diallo n'inventons rien il ad il a
des prédécesseurs mais bon disons de
rares exceptions george et moi je pense
que par rapport à 6 10 c'est un choix
c'est un choix mais on peut pas on peut
pas demander à tout le monde de courir
pieds nus comme on peut pas demander à
tout le monde comme il veut créer un
mouvement en tout cas voilà de bruit un
mouchard mouvance est idiot respectable
il a écrit notamment un livre de 200
pages qui n'est pas encore édité en tout
cas il a écrit un livre pour expliquer
sa théorie et il cherche à attirer de
plus en plus de monde
oui à la course piège la course pmu
j'aime moi je
enfin je le joli j'y crois pas j'y crois
pas et il est peu voilà j'y crois pas
maintenant que lui ici sont ils sentent
bien oui où d'autres se sentent bien
mais il faut pas mettre en mouvement
parce que c'est pour moi c'est un choix
plus un choix personnel c'est un choix
personnel
si vous prenez un les éthiopiens qui
vivent en ethiopie qui s'entraîne en
ethiopie et qui viennent faire les
courses en europe
ils croient ils sont en ethiopie
pourquoi pieds nus et ils vivent en
ethiopie et donc les lie quand ils
arriveront les rediffs et pas la langue
lisant les hésitants les asics donc
ainsi dit ceux qui veulent mettre un
mouvement de course pieds nus non ils ne
s'adonnent pas on doit pas en faire une
affaire quoi une affaire personnelle
certes mais point affirme globale autour
de cette table qui pourrait courir pieds
nus on sait qu elle n a répondu non tout
à l'heure il ya le nom pourriez vous
pouvez rejoindre
mouvement je ne pas courir vous n'aimez
pas comparer pour vous georges je suis
le je les suis
comme je vous dis j'ai les pieds plats
lavit montigny le bretonneux ainsi leur
joie ou non vous non plus du fait de
monter à cheval depuis de nombreuses
années j'ai les jambes très marqué donc
c'est impossible n'avons pas adapté à
tous forfaits en tout cas on passe
maintenant notre focus du jour
[Musique]
coup de tonnerre dans l'organisation des
jo de 2024 à paris la fédération
française d'équitation voudrait que des
épreuves les épreuves équestres ne se
fasse pas à versailles
la raison le site est jugé trop élitiste
et la structure construite pendant les
épreuves ne serait que provisoire mais
un rapport récemment rendu public par le
ministère des sports prévoit toujours
une organisation des épreuves à
versailles on s'engage peut-être vers un
bras de fer entre tous les acteurs
la question sur ce thème faut-il
organiser les épreuves équestres à
versailles oui ou non un voile raul
compte beaucoup dans cette thématique
alors j'ai pris connaissance de la des
différents arguments il est l'instance
en tous les cas qui qui qui se
positionne comme la première à être
contre la conception de de
l'organisation des épreuves versailles
c'est la fédération française
d'équitation et en pesant le pour et le
contre
effectivement en ce qui concerne
l'argument de la durabilité il est
difficile de contrer parce qu'
effectivement construire un stade
éphémère c'est coûteux et effectivement
et c'est très dommage de pas pouvoir
s'en serait de s'en servir après ensuite
il ya autre chose on à la tête de l'as
de la fédération un président serge
lecomte qui a réussi en et l'équitation
vers une démocratisation sans précédent
avec la création du poney club de france
et pour ça je le salue mais c'est ce qui
est ce qui me dérange le plus dans cette
démarche c'est que dans les autres pays
quand on parle de deux traditions ou
d'histoire et c'est de la culture en
france tout de suite c'est élitisme ou
démarche conservatrice
je vois pas en quoi l'histoire du
château de versailles et ce qu'ils
représentent et d'élitisme je dire qu'en
tirer les jo à londres on a eu autant
d'image de foot jeux de sport pardon que
de big ben est chez nous non c'est
élitiste c'est c'est contre ces contre
la démocratisation de l'équitation et ça
je suis pas d'accord et donc je serais
très heureux que ça se passe à
versailles mais effectivement je suis
obligé de reconnaître cet argument du
fait que ça coûte chanson est un stade
éphémère c'est coûteux coûteux et est un
peu normalement voilà le site ne
coûterait rien pas 35 millions d'euros
comme prévu initialement mais près de 80
millions d'euros
alors la chambre ça me dérange parce que
longchamp on est allé ensuite équitation
de faire une démarche de vraiment être à
part des courses dire que les gens même
très souvent quand je quand je dis le
métier que je fais on nous parle tout de
suite des courses et c'est vrai qu'on
aimerait bien que l'équitation soit une
identité à part entière et dissociée du
monde des courses et là on ne les
organisons à longchamp savoie encore
vraiment porté sa confusion fontaine
blues jeu
je suis tout à fait content parce que le
tous les autres sites envisagés par la
fédération française d'équitation
je pense que fontainebleau c'est une
très mauvaise idée de toute façon je
pense que les cavaliers se met fort on
bloque pour pas que ça ait lieu là bas
il faut savoir que la piste de
fontainebleau c'est la raison pour
laquelle il ya plus aucun grand prix 5
étoiles qui est organisée c'est parce
que c'est une piste qui a qui connaît un
énorme dit doublé et est sur un schéma
de championnat où les choses vont
souhaiter plus de quatre fois sur des
codes qui vont vraiment au maximum
il est moi je prends le jeu peut mettre
parier tout de suite à l'avant ce que de
toute façon il y aura des accidents des
blessures au niveau des chevaux ou des
chevaux qui refuseront de sauter parce
que le jeu je considère que pour une des
épreuves olympiques le terrain
fontainebleau il est dangereux
julian voulait réagir oui je reviens de
rio où où j'ai participé au championnat
championnats du monde handisport et sur
le sur piste et donc sur l'anneau qui a
servi aux jeux olympiques est donc dans
le stade olympique
et quand je vois les infrastructures qui
ont été créés pour les jeux olympiques
de rio et le non utilisation deux ans
après ça fait ça fait réfléchir ça fait
réfléchir
et sincèrement quand je suis reparti je
me disais mais pourquoi sur les jo ont
fait pas comme ils ont pu faire pour le
beach volley je lui ai rien sur le stade
le stade olympique qui a un style yahia
il ya une arène qui est pour la qui fait
juste un terrain de tennis et c'est à
rennes aujourd'hui personne ne
l'utilisent et donc pas pour le pour le
beach volley je me souviens que c'était
quelque chose qui était éphémère qui a
été détruit qui a déjà été démontés par
un par la suite et est donc pourquoi
pour les olympiques on ne fait pas
justement du de l'éphémère alors 78
millions pour faire de l'éphémère en
effet ça me paraît
très très coûteux comme
comme installation mais aujourd'hui
toute façon dans le château de
versailles il sera forcément des montées
mais oui d'accord qu'on peut pas
construire un stade qui resterait mais
je pense que je vois pas l'intérêt
d'avoir un stade de grand construire un
stade est-ce que et là c'est la question
que s'est posée à toi raul c'est est ce
qu'il y a un intérêt est ce que la
fédération est ce que le sport équestre
a besoin d'avoir une structure qui
resterait qui serait utilisé par la
suite de toute façon ça c'est sûr que de
l'aider structures équestres en france
pour organiser des gros événements on en
a plein on est on à la ville au monde
qui organise le plus de grands prix 5
étoiles donc on n'a pas besoin d'un
stade supplémentaire d'avoir la pression
donc il n'y a pas d'intérêt et ben ouais
restons sur de l'éphémère pour cet
événement est alors après on va enlever
le côté chauvinisme du fait de se dire
on habite à un habit de proches de
versailles on voudrait qu'ils éprouvent
aussi à versailles et voilà le lieu s'y
prête c'est quand même un lieu
historique c'est quand même un côté très
très sympathique de pouvoir faire de
pouvoir faire quelque chose avait
quelque chose à dire et qui est et
ensuite le sport équestre aux jeux
olympiques fait partie je pas dire des
sports majeurs et fait partie des sports
que l'on regarde et dont on parle quand
on est quand on invite donc le fait de
le faire avec un très beau à très bel
endroit c'est pour moi très important
car il existe pour vous aussi
en fait je pense qu'elle est aussi une
histoire un petit peu caché deux
d'argent qu'en fin de compte à ce qu'on
dit voilà élitiste c'est versailles
éphémère pas éphémère en fait c'est
vraiment je pense plutôt une question
d'argent il en parle on en parle pas
directement la grande question c'est pas
est-ce que c'est élitiste ou pas c est
ce qu on va être prêt de sortir 80
millions par rapport à 35 c sa partie
jean plus c'est pas le lieu
oui c'est pas le lieu c'est purement une
question d'argent conçu politique
oui et puis bon c'est de la logistique
c'est une grosse question
ils disent parce qu'il ya des rois
monarchistes qui a vécu là dedans c'est
pas vrai c'est d'abord le plus beau
château au monde
si on peut pas le mettre en valeur
sur les religions en france c'est
vraiment dommage
annoncé comme ça 80 millions pour je ne
sais pas quels sont les besoins en
termes de voix là ça part et ça me
paraît quand même énorme pour pour wii
on passe du simple au double et pourrait
pour une épreuve qui est de l'équitation
d'obligations en effet il ya le saut
d'obstacles il y aurait il y aurait
aussi les épreuves qui sont plus grosses
le cross est comme ça le cross ça ça
coûte pas grand chose à en gagner quand
même les travaux à faire en milieu
naturel qui sont assez assez colossaux
il faut refaire une piste donc s'aimer
mais bon à partir du moment où il ya une
forêt mitoyenne
effectivement c'est pas ce qui va je
pense qu'ils représentent un coût c'est
pas vrai s'est même pas la carrière
parce qu'une carrière une carrière c'est
une carrière le sable c'est parce qu'ils
coûtent le plus mais je pense que c'est
au niveau des tribunes et tout ce qui
est tout ce qui est à l'accueil du
public ça qui va coûter cher mais de
toute façon s'il fait beau il fait ses
valises et autres par de toute façon je
dire à part la carrière qui est des qui
sera dévala sur un autre site
il ya en a pas on n'a pas un site en
france qui est capable d'accueillir un
public impliqué dans la pizza ou alors
il y aura d'argent dépensé oui voilà ça
peut être possible
voilà mais à l'époque c'était comme ça à
l'époque on organisait tout et puis je
me mariais aussi un autre facteur sont
plusieurs témoignages témoignages a
rapporté par nos confrères de l'équipe
les membres de la fédération française
n'aurait pas été consulté a également 2e
à un peu d'amour propre
bien sûr je croyais que 6 et peser
possible 4
nous a pas demandé l'autorisation
attendait d'être votre avis georges
cellérier vraiment ça me mets moi j'ai
enfin j'y crois mais comme disait tous
les collègues
ça serait dommage de ne pas le faire à
versailles d'autres ont plus que
vis-à-vis du cio sur le dossier s'était
versailles qui a été présenté et puis
maintenant qu'on est con à l'attribution
des jeux on change on change de lieu et
même pour je vois pas l'élitisme là
notre époque d'être à notre époque les
gens ce qu il est jeune il ya quelques
enfants quelques années on peut même
aller pique-niquer puis cliquez
gratuitement le château et les gens y
vont et l'isi vont normalement et les
entrées les entrées on y rentre on y
sort je pense qu'il ya plus d'élitisme
sinon à versailles qui va déterminer le
prix d'entrée ou de sortie cd celozzi
les prix des tickets olympiques
c'est une organisation au dernier lucky
je suis d'une organisation équestre sur
le champ-de-mars roya pas très très bien
sûr le pari eiffel voilà c'est pas
quelque chose a coûté 80 millions
d'onces alors que effet de l'ampleur et
dans sa jeunesse privée et loeb mais
l'ampleur serait la même a perdu sur les
joues et le terrain serait plus grands
il ya trois disciplines
et puis il ya surtout un public à un
public qui à recevoir pour des
événements olympiques mais moi ce qui me
sidère c'est qu'on a une fédération qui
a toujours été désintox et tout
désintéresser du haut niveau et par la
ja il ya un enjeu sportif
on va passer maintenant notre deuxième
focus on va se calmer raul on va parler
football et du jeune prodige yvelinois
gens qui minent augustin le plaisir à
jouer en quarts de finale de la ligue
des reliques de repas contre marseille a
même marqué contre avec son club de
l'exil au retour une équipe allemand
qu'il a rejoint l'été dernier après
avoir porté les couleurs du psg
statistiquement le jeune de 20 ans a
marqué six buts sur 21 matches joués
depuis qu'il est arrivé pour rappel il a
quitté le psg car il ne jouais pas assez
la question sur ce thème at il fait le
bon choix en partant en allemagne oui un
petit duel entre vous raul et jorge j'ai
jamais d'accord et que personne ne le
connaissait bien en plus gentiment
l'industrie c'est un jeune du malibu
donc j'étais le premier régime et donc
je le connais je connais sa famille est
bon il est passé par là si bébé suite à
ça et paris saint germain en u12 et ça
c'est bien très bien passé pour lui bon
après laon le projet du des qatari bon
il pouvait pas jouer vise l'atteinte
cavani cavani et et orly relayée sur le
côté sur le côté gauche lui remplaçant
après il a fait une année là
l'année où il avait été faire le stage
aux états unis la jouer de marquer pas
mal de buts en équipe de france espoirs
il est en équipe de france espoirs est
champion champion du monde aussi en
jeune et bon bah après un moment il faut
jouer quoi il faut jouer on voit on voit
beaucoup de joueurs qui sont dans des
clubs avant ils ont ils ont pas de ils
ont pas de comment ils n'ont pas de il
manque d'expérience après parce qu'il
joue pas contrairement bon état dit le
garçon qui joue en national après belle
touche la ligue 2 puis touche la ligue
la ligue 1 mais ils ont de l'expérience
parce qu'ils jouent alors moi je pense
que c'est un bon choix pour lui parce
que je ne joue pas forcément en
allemagne et en allemagne
il va être amené à jouer parce que là il
a quand même fait 20 matchs et au pg les
faisait pas les bons mais il ne faisait
pas les installer les aurais pas fait on
regarde christophe heim kukulcan en
commun de match il a fait aidé à marquer
des buts mais n'a pas fait il a proféré
lors du paraguay n'a pas fait
christopher cook ou joueur du paris
saint germain et l'a pas fait il n'a pas
fait 20 matchs et comme tout comme
titulaire voilà mes jean kevin je pense
que valence est la première année il
change il change de pays change de il
change de coach d'environnement donc il
faut aussi but pour moi bah 21 22 et 90
ouais il a il doit avoir 20 20 21 21 ans
donc un stage là-bas réel c'est déjà
bien pour une première saison à
l'étranger
l'année prochaine il va partir avec des
européens elle va connaître les
coéquipiers les coéquipiers vont
commencer à le connaître son jeu je n'ai
pas transfert intersaison raoul jean je
le rejoins sur le jeu rejoint georges
pardon ne l'a pas fait le bon choix pour
vous c'est pas dans ma logique
voilà je suis pas assez pointues en
football pour avoir un avis tranché
c'est pour ça que d'abord jauge j'ai
entendu georges et je le rejoins sur le
fait que la pratique c'est important il
faut foulée faux foulée du foulée de la
pelouse pour quand on est joueur il faut
jouer ça c'est sûr maintenant j'ai
toujours tendance à penser que c'est en
se frottant aux meilleurs et en on est
en passe le plus clair de son temps avec
les meilleurs qu'on atteint enfin
football deux classes de classe
internationale donc j'aurais tendance à
penser que quand on est à tous les jours
à l'entraînement avec cavani et zlatan
on s'élève plus techniquement que
qu'avec des joueurs d'une moins grande
classe c'est ce que je pense on est on
est plus amenés à développer un grand
football ou un grand jeu c'est ce que je
pense mais elle est morte en allemagne
aussi l'imaginé pas si peu joué
y est ça aussi voilà j'avais
l'expérience marqué quatre buts lors de
ses deux premiers mois mais son
rendement s'est effondré juste après les
deux mois il a perdu même sa place au
profit du danois youssouf poule cells
qui est devenu le titulaire de l'équipe
finalement il a imaginé prêter la
première chose qu'il aurait peut-être dû
faire c'est d'abord peut-être se faire
prêter une saison ou deux sur et rester
en ligue 1 peut-être à essayer d'aller
d'aller dans l'éclat d'un petit peu
moins un peu moins huppés delà de la
ligue 1 pour pour pouvoir obtenir du
temps de jeu et on obtient ses ligues
nord
oui c'est vrai mais bon la ligue 1 tu
veux il ya un petit peu comme comme les
liens française il ya le bayern et puis
ensuite derrière dortmund il arrivé dans
une équipe qui a fini deuxième à l
équité qualifier pour la ligue des
champions
enfin sauf que cette année ils sont au
milieu de tableau quoi 606 sujet dame au
chapeau ne peut finir est aussi un
commun il reste cinq matches à jouer et
moi je pense que encore accrocher la
ligue des champions ils ont non mais moi
je conserve mon choix d'autant plus que
c'est bon c'est serré de l'airé de la
red bull qui ont qui ont qui ont l'epsic
et le
salzburg aut 6 à ce boucan comme en
autriche et je pense que bombe à l'ailé
en allemagne quand même pas mal de
transfert qui sont qui se font vers
l'angleterre et c'est un club qui monte
oui oui c'est un choix de carrière de
bien sûr bien sûr parce que depuis les
psys qu ils sont montés ils sont ils
sont montés et de l'est de ligue 2 quand
tu aurais pu les arrivées sont montés de
ligue 2 derrière ça ils sont montés en
ligue 1 ils sont ils ont fait une
superbe saison
là ils font l'aller ils ont fait la
ligue des champions c'est comme le moins
populaire d'allemagne populaire le moins
populaire d'allemagne a vu un geyser
manière les informations mais je pense
que à son âge il peut encore il peut il
peut faire un auto que transfert oui et
un ou deux transferts en allemagne
généralement le bayern il affaibli ses
adversaires donc il ya des queues du but
est qu'un joueur brille au pyla ils
emmènent dans leur écurie
donc moi je je je m'inquiète pas pour
lui bon à condition il a coûté garde
également 14 millions d'euros plus 2 de
bonus ça joue forcément aussi peut-être
sur son mental oui c'est plus de
pression il ya de la pression sur lui il
ya de la pression mais bon c'est un
jeune joueur ça c'est un jeune joueur on
n'a pas encore la régularité et en
france malheureusement mais surtout au
bois paris saint germain
on a vu dans le cas de deux joueurs qui
sont partis à l'étranger et qui ont qui
glissent les comme année y en a qui sont
partis comment à manchester city en
france ressort ni trop jeune pour jouer
si on est trop vieux the latin c'est un
moment c'est qu'il est trop vieux donc
c'est un gros problème en france soit
moins les trop jeunes trop vieux mais
quand on est jeune il faut qu'on joue
pour prouver pourquoi on fait venir les
joueurs étrangers qui ont jugé un drap
ce faire il est certain c'est un jeune
joueur
on imagine en allemagne on a fait jouer
à 18 ans justement il ya peut-être
quelques erreurs de jeunesse que gens
qui me augustin a commises notamment
après avoir marqué contre l'olympique de
marseille en ligue europa il a mis son
doigt sur la bouche un geste qui a peu
présomptueux qui n'a pas forcément plu
aux marseillais est également en
allemagne
voilà apparemment ce geste aurait pu
déconcentré l'équipe juste après avoir
mis le but du 3-2 alors on regarde juste
ont cet extrait réalisée par nos
confrères marseillais jean kévin qu'est
ce que c'est que cette célébration
ça n'a pas servi de leçon que ça va tu
sais pas c'est pas bien il faut pas
faire ça au final vous êtes éliminés ce
comme avec di maria
eh ouais désolé comprends pas yann ça me
fait rien mais en effet c'est vrai que
si l'erreur de jeunesse peut-être
motivant problème c'est que en fait il
est désert comme joueur parisien bien
sûr puisque john parry il l'est de la
région parisienne et donc ils marquent
un but contre marseille donc idiot
supporters je suis sauf que derrière il
se prend il prennent 3 1 et et souviens
toi il y avait eu la même chose avec les
france espoirs où justement les linkers
havas avait fait la même chose contre la
suède et au final ils étaient faits
éliminer et il n'avait pas été
les français par n'a pas été ou d'europe
donc voilà c'est juste ça qui lui et qui
lui a rappelé maintenant voilà l'erreur
de jeunesse qui n'a pas forcément en
allemagne mais à son club
bien sûr oui bien sûr cd c'est dommage
parce que je trouve que le
intrinsèquement le foot c'est un sport
qui est élégamment pratiqué par des
athlètes admirable et essayez toujours
ces histoires politiques qui viennent
parasiter l'ambiance et kiki mathilde
déstabiliser les jeunes joueurs en plus
où et c'est vraiment dommage ce d'autant
plus que jouer pour eux c'est pas la
faute à lui je veux pas c'est dommage qu
eux mêmes ces gestes-là qui pour moi
représente rien et une jambe
souvenez vous la pitoyable rapidement
prendre rapidement dû gagner fait la
même chose envers les journalistes quand
il avait marqué son but france france
sud afrique du sud à marseille après 198
santé ça lui a plutôt souri en soit la
bonne il a très bien débuté un match on
passe maintenant notre rubrique débats
dans cette page débat qui sera très
courte nous allons parler de boxe tony
yoka est un homme pressé le champion
olympique originaires de chanteloup les
vignes veut remporter la ceinture de
champion de france des 6 juin le souci
l' agence française de lutte contre le
dopage l'a convoqué pour avoir manqué
des contrôles antidopage entre 2016 et
2017 et il peut avoir entre un et deux
ans de suspension ferme
il a demandé à reporter cette audience
après son combat pour la ceinture contre
raphaël tronché ce qui paraît fortement
hypothétique la question sur ce thème
faut-il être clément avec tony yoka
faut-il être clément avec ce jeune
boxeur de 25 ans je le rappelle d'être
partagée enfin un petit duel entre vous
et hao les et gagne à nouveau cancer
je dis simplement non parce que
aujourd'hui tony yoka est un sportif qui
rayonne au niveau international et on se
doit à son niveau de montrer l'exemple
voilà pour moi il n'y a aucun problème
il n'y a pas de problème de dopage dans
sur sur ce sur ce dossier c'est
exactement la même chose que grégory
baugé il ya quelques années
c'est une histoire de nos choses c'est à
dire qu'ils n'ont pas rempli leurs
devoirs administratif en disant je suis
présent à tel endroit at-elle matin etc
et ils sont venus se faire contrôler et
il y avait et il n'était pas là donc
donc voilà il ya essai si le système est
très très compliqué à gérer pour pour
les sportifs le savoir
donc donc pour moi il n'y a pas de
problème maintenant en effet on doit
montrer l'exemple et on se doit
exemplaire de pourpoint éliminer tous
les toutous les soupçons et donc
donc il faut qu'il faut qu'il ait une
sanction on met le minimum on lui met un
an dans sa carrière ça va pas lui faire
perdre grand chose il va peut-être faire
un ou deux combats de moins sur l'année
et il pourra reprendre tranquillement ça
n'empêche pas de pouvoir s'entraîner
pendant un an de pouvoir même
s'entraîner peut-être plus fort
puisqu'il n'y aura pas de phase ii de
seiche n'y aura pas besoin de
s'entraîner très très fort pendant un an
et revenir à la fin de cette année avec
un niveau qui sera encore plus qu'israël
est super raul paradoxalement j'aime
j'aime hiver alors que noah reconnaître
que yann a dit que des choses qui sont
vraies vrai parce que parce que c'est
vrai que quand on a le coup de
projecteur sur soi et ben on a une
responsabilité vrai parce que la
catégorie des poids lourds on peut se
permettre de vieillir un peu ne pas
combattre et de prendre de la maturité
voilà ce que je lui conseille lui perdu
dans oui mais attention à la catégorie
poids lourds d'abord numéro un français
s'est pas acquis parce qu'il ya quand
même
carlos takam et et johann duhoo parce
qu'ils sont quand même des des guerriers
qui sont déjà montés contre josue
wilders c'est une autre classe encore le
championnat de france pourquoi pas par
contre voilà moi je suis obligé d'avoir
un petit peu de compréhension et
d'encourager à tony parce que ce qu'on
ne sait pas où peut-être vous le savez
mais ce même moment tous et tous ses
rendez-vous qu'il a qui n'a pas honoré
photo cl jeunesse il fait face en ce
moment à une
un coup monté médiatique qui affecte sa
vie privée qui affecte son identité de
mari et de père de famille il a de
nombreux rendez vous chez les avocats
pour gérer cette situation
je lui ferais je pense que je lui ferais
pas du bien en précisant pourquoi mais
en tous les cas il est ennuyé en ce
moment par par le parce qu'ils pensent
que parce qu'on peut produire de plus
sale attention cependant dans le jeu
parfois dans le journalisme est victime
d'un chantage donc pour pour ça je dois
rapidement le rejet juste un tour de
table faut-il lui donner une deuxième
chance
oui on rêver moi je rejoins ce qu'ils
disent par contre je trouve que c'est
vraiment dommage d'arriver à sa juste
finalement par négligence les vosges
orge
moi je suis partagé parce que je me dis
c'est un produit un produit avec 15
secondes un rêve un produit un produit
de beauté divine et moi je le laisse une
deuxième chance allez on
c'est le seul champion du monde des
poids lourds qu'on peut avoir donc
locaux et le ralentir leur le ralentir
vous avez utilisé vos dix secondes
georges c'est la fin de cette émission
se retrouvent le jeudi à troyes mais
pour nous mais l'émission va terminer
par une citation de l'ancien joueur de
l'équipe de france et du paris saint
germain luis fernandez pour gagner il
faut accepter de perdre je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]